et pour en parler nous sommes avec à
laurent alexandre essayiste et
chirurgiens bonsoir laurent alexandre
merci d'être avec nous avons nathalie
ernoult co directrice de l'observatoire
de la santé mondiale à l'iris bonsoir
nathalie ernoult merci aussi à vous
d'être là les etats-unis qui sont
favorables à l'exemption en droit de
propriété intellectuelle sur les vaccins
une prise de position jugée historique
par l' oms on attendait pas
nécessairement les états unis là où
comment avez-vous réagi hier à cette
annonce de washington laurent alexandre
je trouve qu'elle est trading logique
d'abord je voudrais préciser que je n'ai
aucun conflit d'intérêts avec je ne
travaille pour aucun fabricant de deux
vaccins donc c'est mon point de vue que
je dépends et je ne suis pas l'ogc nice
tu ce soir c'est une de fausse bonne
idée car il faut investir des milliards
dans la recherche pour sortir des
nouveaux médicaments aux dix nouveaux
vaccins si on nationalise les brevets il
n'y aura plus de recherche
les actionnaires de modern a investi 5
milliards de dollars il y a dix ans dans
le développement des technologies arn
messager si on leur avait dit il ya dix
ans il était possible que cet
investissement partent en fumée
parce que les brevets ils ont contribué
à financer par les milliards qu'ils ont
investi allait être nationalisées ne
leur est pas investie et donc c'est du
one shot on va effectivement avoir eu
une propriété industrielle gratuite est
donné à tout le monde
sur les pas de saint paul koffi 19 mai
nous n'aurons plus de vaccins dans le
futur c'est à dire que les industriels
n'investiront plus dans l'est dans la
recherche pour les vaccins et en réalité
ça va être une fausse bonne idée qui va
considérablement dégradé la santé
publique et notamment dans les pays les
plus pauvres
puis il ya va y avoir un 2e était
secondaire vous l'avez remarqué angela
merkel ne veut pas se joindre à cet
accord et donc ça no 6 par exemple va
s'installer en allemagne où on va
continuer à protéger les brevets parce
que l'allemagne a bien compris qu'il est
suicidaire pour un pays de nationaliser
et de confisquer la propriété
intellectuelle en matière de vaccins
donc c'est une idée sympathique et
démagogique
que pas mal de pays choisissent pour des
raisons politiques ou géopolitiques mais
ça va affaiblir l'industrie du vaccin et
ça va faiblir la santé publique
et je peux vous dire que dans dix ans on
pleurera parce qu on aura moins de 25
contre les maladies du futur et dans le
futur il y aura d'autres maladies mais
il n'y aura pas de technologies qui
seront développés parce que les gens se
feront avoir une fois mais pas deux
poids
tout le monde va savoir qu'il ne faut
pas investir un tir de vaccin parce que
on se fait voler le vide sa recherche
nathalie ernoult alors vous on imagine
que vous avez accueilli plutôt
favorablement cette décision de
washington
quand vous entendez le docteur laurent
alexandre donner des arguments de bon
sens tout de même qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
que par rapport à ces arguments en
matière de recherche les investissements
dans les fermes ont été massivement des
investissements publics depuis plus de
10 ans en fait il y a eu des
investissements publics pour la
recherche notamment sur les vaccins arn
messagers notamment au travers des
universités et pas du tout au travers
forcément de structures privées comme on
l'entend aujourd'hui du type moderna je
prendrai l'exemple du vaccin
d'astrazeneca qui selon les propos mêmes
d'oxford université d'oxford qui a
développé le vaccin a dit que l'ensemble
de la recherche avait d'ailleurs été
couverte par des financements publics
donc je pense que ce qu'il faut revoir
c'est la notion de recherche et
développement et d'investissement
puisque en particulier dans le cas de
cette pandémie
non seulement la recherche a été en
amont copieusement financé par des
investissements publics mais en plus le
développement c'est à dire le
financement des essais cliniques les
achats à risque de ces vaccins ont eux
aussi été financés massivement avec des
investissements publics ce qui s'est
passé je pense
et ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est qu'on est comme le disait comme
s'était dit dans votre reportage dans
une situation exceptionnelle
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est que les pays
même si à une levée des brevets les pays
pourront choisir de l'appliquer ou pas
d'ailleurs
mais ce qui est important c'est qu'on
est face aujourd'hui dans la situation
de la réponse aux convives un manque de
vaccins un défi culte et à produire des
vaccins dès l'année dernière des
possibilités avaient été ouvertes est
offerte d'ailleurs à l'industrie
pharmaceutique des maîtres des licences
volontaires pour augmenter les capacités
de production ils n'ont pas saisi cette
opportunité et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui quelques mois plus tard dans
une situation compliquée sur le plan de
la pandémie avec une organisation
internationale notamment une
architecture internationale de réponse à
la crise par le biais de la cobac ce qui
est censé délivrer des vaccins dans les
pays à bas revenus et à revenus
intermédiaires qui est en incapacité de
le faire puisque aujourd'hui l'inde qui
quittent qui avait passé des accords
pour justement fournir des vaccins pour
une grande partie du monde n'est plus en
capacité de le faire compte tenu de la
crise
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui qu'en fait
la question c'est de ce que font les
états unis et c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de remettre la santé
publique au centre de la discussion en
disant qu'on est dans une situation
exceptionnelle et qu'en fait il faut
donc mettre en place des moyens
exceptionnels
alors avant de vous faire réagir
évidemment laurent alexandre on va
écouter l'oxfam à
un communiqué donc de l'oxfam qui est un
petit peu dans ce qu'audi le
prolongement pardon de natal hier
nourrit côté l'urgence de la vaccination
mondiale est réel les épidémiologistes
du monde entier nous alerte
nous avons un an sinon moins pour
vacciner l'ensemble de la planète et
atteindre une immunité collective
mondial sans une vaccination massive les
mutations du virus pourrait rendre les
vaccins qu'ovide 19 inefficace non c'est
vrai que laurent alexandre autant on
vous écoute et on se dit les arguments
sont implacables mais cela le sont aussi
en sonate aliern ou et ce2 de l'oxfam il
y a urgence et il faut aller très vite
comment fait-on mais on se fout du
lourde jamais dans l'histoire de la
science on est allé aussi vite en un an
on a réalisé déjà la fabrication d'un
milliard trois cents millions de lots on
a déjà réalisé 1 milliard 200 millions
de vaccinations jamais une industrie
dans l'histoire de l'humanité n'a
développé une innovation aussi vite
jamais les vaccins arn messagers ont été
mis au point en quelques semaines les
essais cliniques ont été tirées en
quelques mois l'industrialisation a été
fait en six mois
c'est une prouesse absolument incroyable
accroît les gouvernements qu'ils font là
de la politique et pas de la santé
publique
on imagine une industrie pharmaceutique
une industrie du vaccin qui glandouille
et qui n'a rien produit
en un an la ville pharmaceutique a déjà
fait un milliard deux cents millions de
vaccinations et à la fin de l'année on
sera sans doute à plus de 5 milliards de
vaccination alors je suis de symptômes
alarmants sont où mais j'ai des
arguments sont totalement démagogique et
le goulet d'étranglement aujourd'hui
n'est pas sur la propriété industrielle
il est sur la sous traitance c'est à
dire que on manque de cuves
si vous achetez une cuve aujourd'hui
elle sera livrée dans neuf mois tirent
les sous très saturé parcours et les
sous traitants des sous traitants de
l'industrie pharmaceutique sont eux même
si vous cherchez à des fioles de vaccins
sur terre aujourd'hui
et bien vous allez voir les commander
mais vous n'aurez qu'à l'automne voire
homo
l'hiver prochain tellement les capacités
de production mondiales sont saturés
donc c'est pas un problème de propriété
intellectuelle c'est un problème
d'organisation industrielle
tous les fabricants dans l'est de
production sont aujourd'hui saturés
il y a un exploit qui a été réalisé est
derrière cet exploit que l'on cache on
essaie de faire croire que l'industrie
glandouille alors que je le répète
jamais une branche industrielle n'est
allé aussi vite dans l'espoir de
l'humanité jamais d'habitude on est cinq
à dix ans pour faire un vaccin là on l'a
fait en quelques mois on a déjà vous
rendez comment qu'on a déjà fait un
milliard deux cents millions de de
vaccination on en sait un million tous
les jours 1 on va bientôt atteindre 2
milliards de vaccination donc ce procès
d'intention pour lequel je n'ai aucun
conflit d'intérêt je le répète il est
absolument scandaleux c'est de la
politique politicienne et la santé
publique va le payer très cher à moyen
terme parce que la recherche en matière
de vaccin va s'effondrer dans les années
qui viennent et elle va se concentrer
dans les pays qui ne vont pas accepter
l'accord dont l'allemagne et je peux
prédire que l'industrie française du
vaccin va traverser le rhin si une
proposition ou si idiote est appliquée
enfin en tout cas vous êtes à peu près
d'accord avec un gala merkel à natal
hier nous en dira merkel qui dit en gros
que voilà ce qui limite la fabrication
c'est ce que vient de dire le docteur
alexandre des vaccins ce sont les
capacités de production et les exigences
élevées de qualité et pas les brevets
même son touch deux côtés d'ailleurs du
pdg de modern ans qui dit accessoirement
après un chute du cours de la bourse à
hier quand on parlait de lever des
vaccins chute du cours de la bourse de
ces laboratoires ne pas avoir perdu une
minute de soleil sommeil nous ne pensons
pas que cela va aider à fournir
davantage le vexin modern ans en 2021 et
demi
22 elle n'est pas là justement la
réalité natale hier non écoutez c'est
vrai que c'est exactement le propos que
tiennent les industriels d'ailleurs et
sans surprise on comprend bien que les
industriels aujourd'hui veulent
préserver la question de la propriété
intellectuelle qui est d'ailleurs un des
éléments importants sur le chemin de
l'accès au vaccin donc il n'est pas le
seul
le seul élément en ce qui concerne les
goulots d'étranglement évidemment ça a
été aussi discuté largement dans un
certain nombre de meetings avec les
industriels et je rappelle d'ailleurs
que aujourd'hui les goulets
d'étranglement qu'on avait pu voir sur
au niveau européen ne serait ce que pour
l'accès des vaccins ont été en partie
résolus après un certain nombre de
pressions politiques d'exigence à
accélérer les faits de la fabrication à
trouver des partenaires pour justement
produire on sait aujourd'hui qu'un
certain nombre de partenaires dans le
monde ne sont pas sollicités et vous
pourrez être en capacité de produire des
vaccins de qualité sans aucun disque ils
le font déjà et donc il est possible de
passer un certain nombre d'accords
donc je pense que moi je souhaiterais ne
pas aller d'une démagogie à une autre
démagogie je pense qu'il ya un chemin
particulier aujourd'hui sur lequel on a
besoin de trouver des réponses
si une sorte plus d'une centaine de pays
soutiennent la demande de levée de
brevets ce n'est pas par hasard
d'ailleurs c'est un peu dommage que
cette demande de levée de brevets se
limite au vaccin puisque il ya un
arsenal thérapeutique beaucoup plus
large qui est nécessaire aujourd'hui
pour combattre le covin mais je
rappellerai quand même qu'aujourd'hui
c'est certes beaucoup de personnes sont
vaccinées tout le monde reconnaît
d'ailleurs les formes en matière de
recherche et de développement je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord avec la
rapidité avec lequel des vaccins ont été
développés mais si je prends aujourd'hui
le continent africain
vous avez très peu de gens qu'ils sont
vaccinés on sait aussi que la
circulation des virus et les mutations
vont créer
distance vaccinale est donc l' oms elle
même a bien clarifier et préciser
puisque c'est son mandat d'ailleurs
qu'il était important de vacciner tout
le monde le plus rapidement possible
donc je crois que c'est derrière cet
objectif que les pays essaye de se
mettre d'accord et on a besoin des
forces de tout le monde je pense que
tout le monde reconnaît d'ailleurs le
rôle des industriels dans cette dans cet
effort là la question c'est de trouver
un juste équilibre entre retenir la
propriété intellectuelle est ce que
disent d'ailleurs de nombreux de
nombreux chercheurs privatiser les
profits alors qu'il y a eu aussi
beaucoup d'investissements publics et je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en allemagne le
vaccin carmack et lui même en partie aux
mains du gouvernement allemand c'est la
même chose aux états unis détiennent
beaucoup de brevets sur les vaccins qui
ont été développés donc tout ceci on le
voit bien n'appartient pas uniquement à
au secteur privé
c'est certain c'est un c'est un effort
collectif qui comprend aussi des
investissements publics et bien sûr des
investissements privés et donc la
question c'est d'essayer de trouver le
juste équilibre pour favoriser en fait
la multiplication des sites de
production et un accès plus rapide en
fait à ces vaccins je crois que c'est de
ça dont dont on parle c'est ce qui est
en jeu et c'est ce qui se situe au sein
de cette décision à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
il devrait y en avoir d'autres
d'ailleurs celle ci ne sera pas
suffisante pour permettre le
développement est en tout cas la
multiplication des sites de production
laurent alexandre on peut effectivement
se demander quelle motivation les états
unis et la russie qui sont détenteurs de
leur vaccin contrairement à la france
qui propose de partager mais qui l'a pas
vraiment fabriquer on imagine quand même
une perte économique assez important
pour ces pays là quelles motivations
selon vous elle est purement
géopolitique
on est dans une partie de go
géopolitique hebeisen fait de la
géopolitique et pout il cède la
géopolitique et l'allemagne qui n'a pas
d'objectif géopolitique n'est pas une
nation militaires comme la russie et les
etats unis est opposée à cette démagogie
dont les motivations ne sont pas de
nature épidémiologique est
public mais purement géopolitique donc
on fait on fait de la géopolitique et ça
se et ça se conçoit la france fait aussi
delà de la politique là puisque comme
vous le savez la france n'a pas de
vaccin puisque pasteur et sanofi se sont
complètement plantés sur leur première
tentative
il y aura peut-être dans quelques mois
un vaccin pasteur mais qui est en
réalité est réalisée avec de la
propriété intellectuelle américaine
puisque c'est une start up américaine
qui va fournir la technologie arn
messagers pour sanofi qui n'a pas été
capable de la développer en propre
donc en réalité la propriété
intellectuelle principal du futur vaccin
sanofi il à eelv a émergé elle est
américaine elle appartient à la pop avec
laquelle sanofi s'est associé pour
contrebalancer l'échec de cette première
tentative
alors on voit bien que ces objectifs de
géopolitique qui sont tout à fait
compréhensibles
ils sont tout à fait noble mais qui va
en payer le prix
c'est la santé publique à cause du
ralentissement inévitable dans les
années qui viennent de la recherche en
matière de vaccins or il ya plein de
maladies pour lequel on n'a pas de
vaccin et on a besoin de l'industrie
pharmaceutiques investissent mais elle
le fera plus car je vous pique votre
maison eh bien vous n'allez pas
construire une autre maison parce que
vous allez être échaudés et là c'est
pareil
le vol de propriété intellectuelle va
conduire à un ralentissement mondial de
la recherche en matière de vaccins et je
le répète et et sa concentration dans
les pays qui vont refuser ce vol de
propriété intellectuelle
donc c'est une fausse bonne idée par
ailleurs ce que les gens ne réalisent
pas c'est qu'on va très rapidement être
en surcapacité mondiale de fabrication
de vaccins car les capter production
augmente très fortement et donc de
canton à distribuer cette propriété
intellectuelle on va se retrouver dès
capacités de production sédentaires des
pays vont ouvrir des usines ils ne
perdront pas parce qu'il y aura trop de
21 ans non une usine de vaccin ça ne
fait pas on skie moi même si je vous
donne la propriété intellectuelle du
vaccin moderna avant de vous fabriquer
un vaccin moderna il va se passer
beaucoup de temps
pas pour demain matin en tout cas on en
rêverait presque 15 ans au scénario
sherlock l'exode
merci en tout cas tous les deux nathalie
ernoult et d'alexandre d'avoir été avec
nous on aura bien compris en tout cas
beau vos de message merci à vous